all right so over the weekend danny
presty he's the co-owner of the staten
island bar
max public house he was arrested for
refusing to abide they say
by new york's draconian coronavirus
restrictions
people everybody at this point knows
about mass and social distancing
some people have an appetite more risk
than others
there's still freedom in this country
according to danny presti's attorneys
backed up by this video the arrest
occurred following this
chase from several deputies by the way
they are not in uniform
one jumps on the hood of the car as you
can see in that video
now and you can see that they're trying
to stop and not drive and get the guy
off the car
presti claims the deputies were dressed
in dark clothing never identified
themselves
claims he was running for his life
police say presti hit
one of the deputies with the car but it
kind of looks like he jumped on it he
was trying to go away
these are reports that the deputy seen
in the
video broke both his legs in this video
provided to us by presti's attorney
you can see police pulling him from his
car our producers did reach out to the
sheriff's office
asking about the deputy's injuries they
wouldn't comment saying the matter was
under criminal investigation
here with the latest max public house
co-owner danny presti is with us
and his attorney louis gellamino is with
us thank you both
you know i'm i'm looking at this as a
former
dishwasher cook busboy waiter bartender
and i'm looking at your business and
you're getting killed
you are every restaurant owner i know is
getting
killed to open the door to either pay
the rent or pay your mortgage put the
lights on
stock the bar hire the people and
these restrictions i mean do people
really understand
your heart life and soul is involved in
this sir
yeah everything uh we put everything
into it just like all small business
owners and that's the whole reason why
we started all this was to bring
attention to it
and say we need assistance uh or we have
to be able to open in a safe way but
just
what they've been doing to us wasn't
acceptable with just dragging this
on for as long as they have and
continuing to do it
now i'll get to the incident that we we
have on the videotape but
let's be clear here i don't think any
american is ignorant
to what risks are with colvin 19 do you
i think we've all learned about social
distancing we've all learned about mass
right is
is it fair to say we all know the rules
if you want to abide by them
absolutely you know in march when they
did the shutdowns we weren't
none of us were really sure what was
going on but as you said i think at this
point
um we're we're all adults and we
understand
what's at risk and what's going on and
your your loyal customers want to go to
your bar
right i'm sure some are wearing masks
some are they what they they are
choosing to go there at this point
now i would advise them don't go around
grandma and grandpa
if you might be exposed don't go around
mom and dad if you're
that's my humble advice what do i know
i'm not a doctor
but i would advise them to take care of
other people i wouldn't want to get
somebody sick
now they're choosing to go to your bar
knowing what the risks are is that a
fair statement in a free society
absolutely right and okay i i happen to
be a freedom guy
myself inform people you know encourage
them to do the right thing right
now the question is these cops were
undercover right they were
not in a marked car is that true
absolutely sean that's absolutely true
they were undercover
they were dressed completely almost
completely in black they had black skull
caps on
and they actually came out from between
two block cars
at 12 20 at night 25 yards away from
danny
behind him and yelled hey presti and
started charging towards him
that was the impetus of him running to
his car as you can see on the tape
it reminds me like you know what was
wrong with the eric gardner case
attorney counselor why are they
arresting a guy
over selling a lucy cigarette to begin
with how stupid is that with limited
police resources right
okay you're going on your own car you
now
i'm sure they'll say that they did
identify themselves
i don't know if we have audio that backs
you up but the bottom line is the way i
saw you pulling away you're trying to
say get out of the way
and you're going slow to start so
obviously
you're scared here too am i wrong in my
interpretation of that
i was scared the entire time i was
scared the entire time from
uh the entire ordeal that happened i was
running for i was running for my life
because that's exactly what i thought
was happening
at no point did i think that those were
sheriffs
you have no idea who these guys are
chasing now you both know i love
i love cops i'm a big police supporter
so do we yeah obviously so
do we these were not nypd cops these
were sharers deputies in
in black clothes that in the police
complaint
in the police complaint it says they
didn't identify themselves they just
yelled
hey prestige at no point did they
identify themselves as sheriffs or any
type of law enforcement or
show any type of bill i don't know if i
should reveal this
danny but i actually know cops that are
telling you privately
whispering in your ear they don't want
to do this to you
they're being forced to have you heard
that from cops
i'm i'm just going to say no comment on
that well they're telling me
i'm going to answer that question we've
heard from many sean
they don't want to be do it's like they
don't want to arrest a guy for
you know for selling loose cigarettes
when you got guys selling heroin and
fentanyl down the block we're wasting
now we got a billion dollars in cuts you
know i just want to say i really really
sympathize for you having grown up in
the restaurant business my dad was a
waiter on weekends i was a dishwasher i
did all these jobs i was a bartender
and you know i kind of admire your
customer base they're loyal people they
know you're in trouble they
want to support local business we've got
to do better than this
and we could if we cared and these
politicians don't care
and i'm really sorry that you're going
through all this to be very honest
sean can i let i just want to say one
thing i want to say to you
that that officer that at no time there
was nobody
that broke two legs that was an absolute
outright
lie by the sheriff's department the
officer you see
running in that video did not break his
legs we have confirmation of that
he wasn't hardly injured they wouldn't
give us an answer thanks for
clarifying that